bonjour je m'appelle les jets une
addiction
tout a commencé quand j'étais jeune
d'autres le faisaient je veux juste
savoir quoi se ressembler si je pouvais
tripes et aussi si je pouvais surfer si
je pouvais partir au début c'était
innocent ton penser que cette innocence
ça passe mais mme mignon puis cité aux
occasionnels mais j'arrivais à faire
part des choses et distinguer les
moments où je profite tellement nous
sommes ennuyés
ensuite petit à petit c'est devenu mon
métier
on m'a fait comprendre que pour percer
dans mon domaine il fallait faire il
fallait les y être les participer et
honnêtement cette époque là je kiffais à
l'époque c'était vraiment qu'ils
faisaient c'est l'époque de la
découverte et découverte des
interactions avec avec déjà rendu quatre
coins du monde avec des stores avec la
jet set des noms de domaine et orcières
s'amusèrent on apprenait aussi ses
failles et énormément appris et ce qu'il
faut classe tu es sétif j'ai beaucoup
flâné je pensais avoir multidrive je
sais que ça peut sembler idiot à tous
ceux qui ne connaissent pas on peut
penser que c'est virtuel que c'est
surfait
mais de plus en plus ce que je faisais
là bas avait de vrai impact sur mon
quotidien
j'ai rencontré de véritables amis des
échanges de confiance et ensemble on a
produit ses pleins de choses à la clé
des mouvements et peut-être sans doute
même dit on parfois m'a fait une
différence
peut-être même plus changer des vies
puis on se marrait bien assez and blade
est tellement de de même de forêt a
passé c'est vraiment bien c'est ce qui
le rend humble payer est quelque chose
de vraiment plaisant de leurs en flat
r&d jouissif même voir toutes ces
interactions mais également avoir nos
communautés et grandir voir supporter
anwar un leak et à une voix haute 8es
à l'elite les ribéry tweet nous encore
les réponses de célébrités ça c'est dur
à expliquer ça correspond vraiment à des
des pics de dopamine un temps ça fait un
bien fou se faire la guerre tu t'es
passe par greg egan voir dans des
interactions avec avec fribourg où burns
c'est un truc de fou mais quand vous
écrivez celui qui est des îles centaines
des milliers de lacs et de rituels
au fil des années la dopamine ne
suffisait plus vous devez vraiment des
doses énormes ça ait un effet c'est pas
que j'apprécie plus d'avoir dix ou
trente lac mais c'est plus à même
euphorie c'est désormais une flot des
têtes aux énormes et ses 12 10 100 fois
plus grande qu'à membres pour ressentir
quelque chose puis c'est plus pareil
un engouement initial qui qui a disparu
certains parlent de deux balles tripes
d'autres parleront de leur dose je ne
sais pas comment décrire c'est plus
pareil
quelque chose quelque chose a changé et
a que chez moi au fil des années j'ai vu
des amis arrêtez d'autres ont persévéré
j'ai des amis qui ont essayé de quitter
mais ils sont venus il y en a aussi qui
qui veulent se lancer mais qui sait
jamais je pense que c'est vraiment une
question de bon équilibre à trouver
mais si je suis ici aujourd'hui c'est
parce que parce que je n'arrive pas à
trouver cet équilibre
j'arrive pas à décrocher
j'arrive pas à faire la séparation entre
le moment où je profite et où je
participe comme il le faut pour moi et
pour les autres et ces autres au moment
où j'y suis en fait en fait j souffre
c'est soit au plus tard le lendemain
parfois même le surlendemain que parfois
après avoir consommé pendant toute la
nuit je mens compte de toutes les
lettres d'hoover que toute cette douleur
que je m'inflige vous que c'est que ces
réseaux m'infliger tout l'angoissent la
colère enfin la la haine que je ressens
quand je suis là bas et quand j'ai été
là-bas
cette colère qui parfois on gagne
parfois pendant des jours et là je le
sais je devrais raccrocher je devrais
m'en éloigner métro ce moment il ya des
systèmes à 7,7 partie instinctive du
cerveau elle reprend les cordes et ce
sont bien souvent quand je suis fatiguée
trop le téléphone et il me fait aller
les bras
parfois
souvent en fait ce zombie les lire pas
dans cette triple i il est sur le
téléphone il là et que des trucs qui re
tweetent d'autres de 38 et parfois même
avant que je fus en soient conscients
valiquer truc que j'ai pas vraiment lui
il va recruter des trucs qui j'ai pas
pris le temps d'analyser et quand je
suis là bas je vais en fait ils sont si
souvent fait déposséder de moi comme si
c'était pour moi qui étais au contrôle
comme 6 mhz comme s'il y avait besoin de
d'exorciser quelque chose en moi qui me
fait aller là bas et qui pour l'instant
trop souvent contrôler tout ce que je
fais je suis là bas alors oui je sais ce
que vous allez dire que j'envisage des
des cures de désintoxication et j'en ai
fait j'ai essayé de couper
je suis même forcé à arrêter pendant
pendant des semaines je vais me passer
un mois qu'ils sont les réseaux sociaux
et où ils furent clairement l'intérêt à
chaque fois j'ai vu chaque fois que j'ai
fait une cure de désintoxication je suis
gelé santis ça me fait du bien je
respire plus trop qui mord librement
plus plus plus facilement un jeu dans
mieux j'aimerais tellement mieux dormir
puis je réfléchis mieux j'ai
l'impression de pour retrouver mon
attention que puis j'ai perdu
malheureusement
la nature de mon métier fait que je ne
peux pas complètement coupée il faut il
faut que j'y retourne
q que j'y sois régulièrement c'est juste
de mieux consommer de consommer plus de
modération
parfois j'arrive à rester sous contrôle
mec trop souvent trop souvent jeu sur le
chute
c'est plus fort que moi la diction est
trop grande je n'arrive pas je serai pas
oublier mon téléphone chaque pomme
détacher de twitter
je n'arrive pas je n'arrive pas de ne
pas y penser
même quand je sais que ça morde
conséquemment triste écoulé 2 de
m'ouvrir le monde sait que ça me rend
fier bien sur moi-même sur mes chambres
d'écriture sont les alliés de
circonstance
même quand je sais pertinemment que en
prenant mon téléphone je suis rentré
dans des discussions et je vais me faire
agresser et je vais répondre je vais
agressive je vais dire des choses que je
vais regretter même si je sais que à
chaque fois que j'y vais je sais qu'à
chaque fois que j'y vais je vais prendre
des coups je sais que je vais donner des
coups et que c'est pas bien c'est mal
pour pour moi et si mal pour les autres
je n'arrive pas à décrocher trop son jeu
je suis content
l'addiction est trop grand l'addiction
est trop grande